The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Schedule for the
remainder of the semester.
Today is a short week.
Normal day today, slightly
different day on Wednesday.
I'll talk about that
in the lecture today.
Basically we hope to have the
official class ended by 2:00pm.
So 1:00 to 2:00 will
be class on Wednesday.
After 2:00, working
in your groups
or taking off early if
you need to take off early
for a flight or whatnot.
So it's up to your
teams, whether or not
you're working in here
or not on Wednesday.
This is also going to be
the last lecture by us,
I believe, on the schedule.
Next week we've got
two guest lectures.
One, on December 1
we've got a panel
from the Indie Game Collective.
They're going to be talking to
us about the business of making
Indie games.
Two people who have their own
businesses, their own studios,
and how their studios
work together.
So that should be
interesting for you.
And then on December 3,
on that Wednesday, we
have Sean Baptiste from
Fire Hose Games talking
to us on marketing,
communication, and community
management for games.
Because we're seeing you can't
just put out a PR release
and buy some
advertising, you need
to build a community if you're
making games professionally.
You need to find your
players, because there's
lots of games they could be
playing besides your own.
So he'll be talking
to us about that.
The week after that
is entirely based
around your presentations.
So December 8 is a rehearsal
in class, live reversal
with your game.
If your game works on
that date-- hopefully
it will-- but
definitely your slides
and your spoken presentation.
We will give you feedback, you
will then take that feedback,
improve your presentation,
improving your grade,
and give it as the final
presentation on Wednesday,
December 10.
At the end of the class on
December 10 it'll be open play.
So after all the
presentations are over
we're going to have
some guests here.
You'll be able to
open your laptops
and play each other's games and
have guests play your games.
So that should be
fun and exciting,
and maybe a little
scary, which is good.
So plans for today then.
I got caught on that--
not 5 minute, but 2 minute
presentations.
Basically short,
informal presentation
just like we did a few
weeks ago, I believe.
We'd like to know about the
status of your game, what
features you're working
on, what features are not
being worked on right
now, what features
might be dropped and cut, and
I'd also like to see your game.
So if you have got
one person talking,
maybe another person showing the
game, maybe playing the game.
This could be what the
game looks like today.
This could be the version of
the game you tested last week,
but have something
show-able, something
visual for us to see so
that we can-- when you're
talking about your
game we understand
what you're talking about.
With no slides, of course,
for this presentation.
For presentation on
8th-- on the 10th
that is more formal,
slides, all the good stuff.
There's a description
about that in Stellar
and we'll talk more
about that next Monday.
After that I'm going to
give a short, about 30
minute, lecture on
cutting features,
some strategies on how to
do it, why you should do it,
things like that.
Might be obvious,
may not be obvious.
After that is work in class.
Pablo is here to give you
feedback on your games,
so we'll be giving you
feedback on your presentations.
If we have questions about
what you just talked about,
but also he'll be going
around and available for each
of your teams to talk about
the status of your game
and what's going
on with your game.
That is class today.
Any questions?
All right.
So it is 1:10.
Are all the teams feel ready
to give presentations right now
or do you need a couple minutes?
AUDIENCE: Couple minutes.
PROFESSOR: Couple minutes?
All right.
So we're going to
give you 5 minutes.
1:15 I'm going to come
back up here and Snap
is going to start.
TEJ CHAJED: All right.
Hi everybody.
I'm Snap-- I'm from Snap.
I am not Snap.
I'm Tej.
And so we've made a lot
of progress on our game
and we've been able
to run it a few times,
but it has not changed a lot
since probably anybody who's
played the game has seen it.
So I'll just go ahead and
play one round of the game
just to show off what we
currently have, and then I'll
talk a little bit
about what we're
planning to do in the future.
So everybody from the
team, you want to play?
And can somebody start the game?
AUDIENCE: I got it.
TEJ CHAJED: All right so the
way this game works is we're
going to throw out a topic.
In this case it's animals.
We're all going to try
to enter as many animals
as we can think of, and we'll
get points whenever two of us
enter the same animal.
All right.
And they can obviously
all cheat, but let's--
AUDIENCE: Wait, we
already started?
TEJ CHAJED: Yes, we started.
Obviously I would not be
showing this normally.
This is a little bit
easy to cheat on.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
TEJ CHAJED: Although we've had
some other forms of cheating.
When Andrew was here,
they just entered A, B, C,
in a row next to each other.
Anybody want to help?
AUDIENCE: Cow.
TEJ CHAJED: Cow.
I guess this is also cheating.
AUDIENCE: Lemur.
Snail.
AUDIENCE: Scorpion.
AUDIENCE: Amoeba.
AUDIENCE: Jaguar.
AUDIENCE: Chicken.
[INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: Pig.
AUDIENCE: Paramecium.
AUDIENCE: Veal.
[LAUGHTER]
TEJ CHAJED: Veal
is not an animal.
I guess baby deer is.
AUDIENCE: Geese.
Human.
TEJ CHAJED: All right.
So I think that
gives you an idea
of how this game plays out.
Can somebody stop the game?
AUDIENCE: I got it.
TEJ CHAJED: So
right now we have--
AUDIENCE: [? Yes. ?]
[LAUGHTER]
TEJ CHAJED: So right now
we have the game completely
manually controlled.
And this is because current use
case-- in our current use cases
for the client
we've been playing
the game with a limited
number of words input
and without a time limit.
So we let the client
just implement
whatever time they want by
starting and stopping the game
appropriately.
But we plan on also supporting
an actual strict word
limit as well as a natural
time limit that can
be displayed on the front end.
We initially went
with Phaser because we
had a much different idea of
how we would represent the game.
But we ended up
focusing more on words
and, like, a more
bare-bones representation.
And so we're actually
going to remove Phaser.
Right now this is
a Phaser window,
but it's not really
helping us at all.
We're just entering
words into a list.
So we're dropping all
of that and moving
to just normal CSS, HTML.
We are also planning on-- we've
experimented in our thought
processes about
what sorts of ways
we want to show
scores and activity.
We want to be able to show not
just what words you're scoring
and submitting, but also when
are other people submitting
words, when are other people
scoring, how am I doing
relative to everyone else.
So we have a couple
ideas around that.
We also would like to show
you a word cloud in real time.
We currently have a word
cloud for the back end.
So this is the game
we just played.
And this is a-- and
this is something
that you can watch
actually as a moderator,
while you're playing,
in real time.
And then here's
another game which
is an actual game that the
client ran in Berlin a week
or so ago.
So that was kind of
cool that we actually
were able to do a real
playtest with the actual client
in the real world.
But in the future we
definitely want this
to look more interesting and
to feel more competitive.
We want people to be able
to see what else is going on
in the game, whereas right
now you really can only see
your scores.
Any questions?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] questions
or comments, [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: What's your
biggest risk right now?
Like, what's the thing
that's most catastrophic?
TEJ CHAJED: I think
since we're switching
the front end over to sort
of new technology we need
to make sure that a, that
transitions over well,
and b, that we have enough
time to finish something
new and useful rather
than just reverting back
to what we have now.
AUDIENCE: How does Snap happen?
TEJ CHAJED: So we
have a server that
is receiving all the words.
And whenever it gets
a word it adds it
to a list of words for a player.
And then every time
it gets a word it also
checks against all other lists.
AUDIENCE: So it's
basically any other player
types the same word?
TEJ CHAJED: Yes.
In the same game.
So for example, the
game is now over.
If you started a
new game, that's
an independent word list.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Just for curiosity,
so let's say you put in "dog"
and [? Priam ?] put in "dog"
and then Sam put in "dog"--
TEJ CHAJED: Everybody
gets one point right now.
We're thinking of
changing that and letting
people get more than
one point, or maybe even
making it configurable.
Most likely--
intuitively it seems
that you should get more if more
people have entered the word.
PROFESSOR: Thank you.
TEJ CHAJED: All right.
[APPLAUSE]
PROFESSOR: Next up
is Awesome Cholera.
Yes, that is not the real title.
PABLO: While Awesome Cholera
or other real title shows up,
we will have a long
conversation about details,
but I'm very excited
about the fact
that it's already
being used and working.
And now the question
will be how many features
you want available to
the [INAUDIBLE] player.
And that selection
process will be
based on both client need,
playtesting, and also
your ambition on how much can
be accomplished in this time.
[INAUDIBLE]
STUDENT 1: Do you want
to do the talking?
STUDENT 2: Yeah.
So this was the last build
to the game we playtested.
We hadn't changed a lot.
We tried to add
instructions so that people
kind of knew what was going on.
And this is running, right?
Can you click Start?
So right now this is what people
saw. they saw their villages,
and some health bars.
It was still kind of unclear.
And over here you can see, like,
the text is still really small.
And when people
clicked something
to do education or
something they either
thought that, like, when
they clicked that button
it instantly did it.
They didn't know
that was a button--
like Educate About Soap was
a button they could click.
Also we had this really
terrible pop-up bug
that we're still trying to fix,
but hopefully that'll be fixed.
And so because we were having
so many problems with the GUI
we finally sat down and
tried to redesign it.
And so I haven't actually--
we haven't done this yet,
but here are some really
great drawings-- A plus,
I said-- of what the
new GUI will have.
So above each locality we're
going to have this little box.
I kind of stole
it from [? Civ ?]
and a few other
places, but-- So it's
going to have the
name of the locality.
And it's even worse
because it's going
to look different from what this
is because we've already talked
about how we want to change it.
And so behind the work
locality is going to be a bar,
and the bar is going
to have a percentage
green and a percentage red.
And the percentage green
will be the percentage
of people in that
locality that are healthy,
and the red will
be the percentage
of people that are unhealthy.
Above that-- sorry.
Above the word Locality, there's
a little arrow that represents
the infection rate,
which is something--
a lot of people used that
word and thought that was
the information they were
getting, but they weren't.
They were getting the
percentage of people infected.
And so a lot of
people wanted to know
how's the infection
rate being changed.
And so we're going
to have an arrow.
And right now it's just going to
be, like, up if it's positive,
down if it's negative.
But we want to also change
it so that they can tell
the magnitude of that as well.
But we're also
trying to keep it so
that people aren't getting too
many numbers thrown at them.
So we're still trying
to iron that one out.
Below the Locality
are a bunch of symbols
representing the different
things you can do.
What we thought we
were going to do
is if you've implemented them
they'll be there in color,
and they'll be counting down
so you know how much longer
that will be in effect.
And they'll also have a gold
ring around them or something
to say, like, if you've educated
[? them ?] about it which
means it's more effective.
And then the other
screen is the screen
you get when you click-- there
will be a little thing that
says Aid Locality above
the Locality thing
for each of the
different localities.
And over [? on this ?] screen--
[? which ?] [? got kind of ?]
messy-- but it'll show all
the things you can do instead
of just the ones
that are unlocked,
because a lot of people didn't
know that things unlocked over
time.
So we'll have it
showing everyone,
hey, these are all the
things and they'll eventually
unlock, either over time or
if you do a certain thing.
And there will be
two columns, one
for educate and for prevent.
And as you mouse over everything
on the right-hand side
of the screen, the
description will come up
telling you about the
effectiveness and the duration,
and giving you a description
of what it's doing.
We're hoping that this'll
make it more clear
as to what everything's
doing, and it'll
be easy to read chunks.
So if they want to
know more about it
they can mouse over it
and just kind of read it.
Or if not they can just
kind of quickly say,
hey, this is pretty
effective but the duration's
short so I'll just use this
for a bit because it's cheaper
and then maybe I'll
use the thing that's
even more effective and
has a longer duration when
I have more money.
The other thing on the
map that I didn't scan yet
is, on the map, on
the very top of it,
we're going to have a bar that
tells you about what day it is
and when you're getting
money, because a lot of people
were like, why am
I getting money?
And they didn't know
time was passing.
So we want to make all
these things clear.
And so I think the GUI
redesign will help with that.
Hopefully we should have
it done after Thanksgiving.
But yeah.
That's where we're at right now.
Any questions?
PABLO: I have one,
but you guys first.
Anybody?
STUDENT 2: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Is your goal for
people to win this game
and then have done
the right things?
Or is it for them
to lose the game
and then, based on that know
what the right thing they
should have done is?
STUDENT 2: Right now
the game's really hard,
and it ends up you kind of lose
if you just leave it alone,
which is not what we wanted.
STUDENT 1: As you saw, earlier,
it just went to game over.
STUDENT 2: We want them to
realize the different things
they can do.
I don't think it's going to be
superbly challenging right now,
is what I'm imagining.
Because you don't want
people to do these things
and then be like,
oh, these things
obviously don't work because
I keep losing the game.
We want them to know that,
like, hey, if I do these things
it will help.
And so that's what we're
trying to get across.
STUDENT 1: Another idea I think
that we're not communicating
effectively but [? is ?]
[? an ?] idea we also want
to communicate is that
the position on the map is
important.
So like if the village
is-- upstream villages--
stuff you do there compounds
to the downstream villages
just because, like, the water,
you know-- if you're not
treating the water correctly
in an upstream village
that water is going to
be contaminated down
to the downstream village.
And at the end we also want to
communicate through this game
is that, like, if you focus
on the upstream villages
you'll have better results
in the long-term because--
AUDIENCE: So I guess how
would I discover that?
Is that just playing the
game many, many times?
STUDENT 1: Exactly.
So that's something we
have yet to communicate.
And we should figure out
a way to communicate that
to the audience.
PABLO: So thank you.
Good luck reconfiguring
the things
that need to be reconfigured.
My intuition is that you would
be better off [? amputating ?]
choice, and leaving somewhere
very visible [? other ?] that
says, these are other things
that could be done but are not
represented in this game.
Because otherwise it will
be just too [INAUDIBLE].
And unless you make
a really awesome game
that people want
to play and play
until they've tried everything,
it can be too intimidating.
STUDENT 1: OK.
PABLO: One of the options
for your consideration--
because right now you
have the options of soap
and the latrines and vaccination
and so on-- you could reduce it
to the things that the
player, the macro-decider
could do in terms of
public awareness campaigns.
So it could be about
[INAUDIBLE] the water,
about washing your
hands campaign and maybe
one more thing.
So limited to three things
that are of the same kind--
you know, radio advertisement or
sending people to [INAUDIBLE].
And maybe less villages.
Again, just reduce choice.
Reduce features so the gameplay
experience is more engaging.
I just want you to
know this is also
applicable to the
other Cholera team.
The Ghana team is now really
interested in promoting hand
washing because it's beneficial
both to cholera and to Ebola,
which is a serious
threat in the area.
So you are [? already know ?]
doing what you're doing
and if hand washing does not fit
in the game, that's fine, OK?
You are doing what we
asked you months ago,
not what we say now.
But if you find a
way to make hand
washing fit as one
of the choices,
it's much better than
having three vaccination
choices and two moving waste
choices and stuff like that.
STUDENT 2: OK.
PABLO: Good.
And good luck.
STUDENT 1: Thank you.
STUDENT 2: Yeah, thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
PROFESSOR: Hello Waves.
STUDENT 3: Our game
is called Hello Waves.
We don't have the
title screen in yet,
but the idea is still
forecast-based financing.
So it's a little
washed out on there.
But if you can see there are
these five different sand
castles with workers
associated with each.
And up here in corner
we have a forecast
of what the water level will
be like in a couple days.
This is the water level right
here, and throughout the game
it'll rise and fall.
And the idea is not to
let your workers get
drowned by the rising water.
The other aspect of
the game though it
that you have a certain
amount of supplies
and whenever you move
someone from their castle
in order to prevent
them from getting
drowned, they will consume
supplies from that stock.
And if you don't have
enough supplies then
they all take damage.
So as you can see,
right now everybody's
in their own castle.
If we click Next Turn the
water level will change
and we'll see that the
forecast will update.
We have a range of
values on this forecast,
a high prediction
and a low prediction,
and if you mouse over
any of the castles
you'll see a red line
appear on the forecast
just to help you orient what
heights are on the forecast.
Or if you're looking
at the forecast, what
it is in the real world.
So you can see the water move.
For these couple days right
now the forecast is pretty low.
If we see that's
kind of getting close
and we're worried about someone
we can click and drag them
to another castle, and on the
next turn they'll move over.
You can also click
people to toggle
between building and gathering.
It's very hard to
see the status text
right now because it's small.
We threw that in
quickly for right now.
But he is set to
building and these three
are set to gathering.
So we'll see that each
turn these three will
gather one supply each.
This teddy bear
will consume one,
so we'll see supplies
go up by two,
and victory progress
will go up by one.
What we have planned
for the rest of the game
is we've made a lot
of progress in terms
of the intuitiveness of the
game, once you understand it,
but right now, there's a
lot in the game that isn't
explained from the get-go.
And so if I give
that spiel to anyone
they can play the game fine
and they do pretty with it.
But if you just open up
the game, you're lost.
So a lot of our work is
going to be on the UI,
of making things
more self-evident
and making sure that people
can understand what's going on
and what their actions
will do without me having
to stand there and tell them.
PROFESSOR: Any questions?
All right.
So I'm going to ask you again,
what is the biggest risk going
forward?
STUDENT 4: I mean,
I think in terms
of our technical
implementation we've already
got good playtests
of our work done
and we have, like, all
of our major graphics in
and things like that.
So I think our major
risk going ahead
is not being able to
explain the game properly.
And so even if we
have finished product
it may still not
be playable if we
don't write good introductions.
PABLO: All right.
So on that front think
of incremental additional
features.
So the games with the
super simple, even
maybe too boring choices,
but then a new choice arrive.
So the learning
be playing can be
staggered in a way that
is [? enjoyable ?].
Good.
Good luck to you, and we'll
talk more about choices later.
I should say that this
high versus low prediction
is something that I
wish scientists did,
like you're doing.
Because most people
say one value,
then it's not that
value [INAUDIBLE]
earlier that
[INAUDIBLE] forecast.
Good.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
PROFESSOR: Heat
Wave, come on down.
STUDENT 5: So the main
things that Heat Wave
is focusing on right now are
playability and education.
As you can see this
is our start screen.
It doesn't have
any instructions.
It's very lame.
We're completely redoing that.
We're also redoing our end
screen and our forecast screen
because we want visual
consistency and just
overall improved
playability by making
the gameplay states more
clear and more connected
to each other.
The other thing we're working
on is we don't currently
have an explicit end condition.
You kind of just play for
however you want to play,
and we're going to add in
like a something happens
that eventually too many
people faint, get heat stroke,
the game's over,
so you have more
of an incentive to play well.
And then finally something we're
working on is user investment.
So we are actually--
where's my mouse?
Sorry.
We are currently working
on redoing pretty much all
of our character
graphics because we
think that having better
character graphics
will make the game
more intuitive.
So one of the ways you play
this game, if you haven't played
it before, is you have
a bunch of characters--
I'll show in a
second-- and you click
on them based on different
characteristics to try
and offer them
water or tell them,
maybe you should go inside,
it's really how out today.
And different people will
react differently to you.
And right now you have
a bunch of characters--
where's my mouse?
And I'm going to play this.
They all look pretty
much the same.
And we have labels--
[LAUGHTER]
Uh, you're already laughing.
Did something--
AUDIENCE: There was a flare.
STUDENT 5: Oh, yeah.
So I'll talk about that
in a second as well.
[LAUGHTER]
So we wanted to increase
emotional investment
in this game.
So one thing I talked about
was an explicit end condition.
The other thing is-- we
know that setting on fire
is extreme and, at this
point, kind of funny.
We all just laughed.
It's not meant to scare you, but
it is meant to make you care.
Before, we just had
people disappearing.
And, number one, people
didn't know that people
had disappeared on the screen.
Players were like,
what happened?
Suddenly there are less people.
And then they'd get
to the newspaper scene
and they'd say seven
people have fainted.
Nothing.
So we added the fire just as
a somewhat comedic element,
somewhat just emotionally
investment element.
I don't want my people to
get set on fire, you know?
So that has to do
with playability.
And also the same thing with
the graphics and the fire,
is education.
We wanted to make this
stick with people long-term
and we thought
that maybe having,
like, a more surprising reaction
to them not doing anything
would make it stick with them.
Something else we're working on
[? with get ?] education is we
need better and more dialogue.
So we redid the backend of
our system for dialogue,
and it doesn't-- uh-oh.
Sorry.
I'm really bad at this.
We redid the backend so that
it would support better choice
trees.
We haven't actually
added the content yet,
which is something we're
working on right now,
but we have the
whole backend working
so that you can make decisions
that actually really do
effect what happens next.
Something people
complained about throughout
is they felt like their decision
weren't having an impact.
That's going to be a
lot more clear now.
And then finally we're
implementing on setting up
longer-term choices.
So right now you
can click on people
and you might talk to
them and they might not
accept the water, they
might accept the water.
You might have a discussion
with them and make them drink.
But we wanted to have
longer-term choices.
So what if you wanted to set
up a public water fountain
or something like that?
And another thing that
we're talking about
is setting up
umbrellas and it might
be worth more of
your time to just,
you know-- the forecast
for the next day
it might say it's going to be
108, but today it's only 80,
so let's set up a
water fountain today
so that tomorrow all the people
can just get water and be
a little healthier.
So that's the two things
we're focusing on,
playability and education.
And we still have a lot of
work to do, which is obvious,
but we've done a lot of
the backend work already
and we think it's
going pretty well.
Any questions?
PROFESSOR: Questions anyone?
STUDENT 5: Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
STUDENT 5: Oh, Julia did this.
Isn't it pretty?
AUDIENCE: That's dope.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
STUDENT 5: It is dope.
I agree.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
[LAUGHTER]
STUDENT 5: Any other questions?
PABLO: Thank you.
Quick comments.
I agree with the idea of making
something like the flame that
is visually compelling.
You may want to think-- if
that's what you end up, fine.
But beware that the idea
of fire is very much
elicits a hazard,
something external,
whereas the nature
of the heat wave risk
is a combination of the
hazard like the fire
and the vulnerability
of the player.
How susceptible
are you, which is
different from an
elderly asthmatic person
versus a healthy sports person.
So if you can brainstorm
about how to depict that,
which can be more
evocative of the fact
that it depends on
the person and not
just some external thing.
STUDENT 5: OK.
PABLO: I have no idea how.
Maybe it's not doable,
but if you can,
that would be
[? an invitation. ?]
STUDENT 5: And
even if we can't do
that we're going
to try to implement
that same concept
through the dialogue
by making the dialogue very
specific, based on the person.
PABLO: Excellent.
Great.
STUDENT 5: Yeah,
you had a question?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
We found the fire funny.
Do you think everybody
would find it funny?
STUDENT 5: So you have to
think about the audience
for this game.
The audience for this game
is the Red Cross worker.
Now I don't necessarily
think that all of them
will think it's funny,
but they'll definitely
elicit some reaction, and I
think that's what's important.
Because before in
our game we weren't
eliciting any sort of reaction,
so it wasn't memorable.
The fire might be funny to some,
it might be scary to others,
thinking about people going
on fire, I don't know.
Me, personally, I think
it's a little terrifying.
But either way it
elicits a reaction.
That's really what
we're going for.
Any other questions?
PABLO: One minor comment.
STUDENT 5: Yes?
PABLO: Most of the
rest of the world
uses degrees Celsius as
opposed to Farenheit--
STUDENT 5: Oh.
PABLO: So consider having
a choice for [? that. ?]
STUDENT 5: That's
a great suggestion.
Thank you.
We'll take that
into consideration.
You had a question?
PROFESSOR: And
your biggest risk?
STUDENT 5: Our biggest
risk is-- so we're not
adding any features, but
from our product backlog
it's just we're redoing a lot.
So just the sheer amount
and the breakdown of work--
it's just we're redoing a lot.
PROFESSOR: And
that's content work,
or is it front and
backend work still?
STUDENT 5: So we redid a
lot of the backend already,
but in terms of the adding of
objects, that's more backend.
But in terms of the dialogue
and stuff, that's more content.
So we have work on both sides.
PROFESSOR: OK.
STUDENT 5: Thank you.
PROFESSOR: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
Next up is Saving
the Animal Village.
STUDENT 6: OK.
So I'm just going to start
talking while Justin sets up.
We are a subset of Saving
the Animal Village.
And our game is trying to
teach cholera prevention
through a series of
minigames, three.
And then the story
is that the mayor
needs help deciding
whether or not
cholera is what is
plaguing the city
or if it's this monster that
you encounter in the beginning.
And so the player will go
through, explore the town,
and try to convince the mayor
that it is, indeed, cholera.
The most prevalent
things that we
need to fix, I guess-- the
prevalent problems that we need
to fix are-- when we playtested
with Pablo some time back
he noted that our minigames--
for example, the filtration
minigame-- wasn't
really something
that would connect to our
audience, which were children
who were in affected areas,
like Ghana, from the ages of 8
to 13.
And we had this, like,
factory setting before
and it was not something a
child would encounter ever.
So what we're changing it to is,
it's going to be inside a home
and a mother's going to be the
one that's bringing the water.
And it's going to
be basically things
that children that will
be playing this game
can relate to.
And we're still in the
progress of changing that.
And we're also in the progress
of adding conversation UI
that's functional
and that we can
use while not alienating the
lower range of our age range.
Because Pablo mentioned that the
children in Ghana [? who are ?]
8 years old might not be
able to read as well as
we want them to.
So we're going to have
more visual instructions
as well, which is important.
And that will probably
be the deciding factor of
whether or not this
game will be successful.
I would say the
thing that is keeping
us back the most right now
is the art, which we have
to synthesize to
match Ghana culture
and communicate our
message as well.
We're also attempting to
implement a way to integrate
the minigames more
through our main scene,
but we'll see how much progress
we get through [? and ?]
[? we'll have ?]
[? to correct ?] that feature.
Any questions?
PABLO: Just one clarification.
When I referred to
matching, I like
what you just showed way better
than what was there before.
And I think if this
is the end aesthetic
of that minigame, that's fine.
My inclination is to
think not so much matching
to Ghana culture, but making
it more adequate or suitable.
So if it looks like science
fiction to a Ghanaian child,
that's fine.
There must be someone from
Ghana around the Boston area.
Send an email, talk to
taxi drivers, I don't know.
Just like you're doing
playtesting with kids,
try to find someone from
West Africa, if not Ghana
so that they can
tell you, no, cats
are actually
spiritually poisonous
or whatever they may say.
I have no idea.
But you want to get
some kind of feedback.
I love cats.
I hope they're not
spiritually poisonous.
Good.
And then there were
many, many games.
We will converse later,
but this core idea I think
is a very useful one.
I'll be keen to learn more about
how the game can be adjusted
in terms of speed of learning
and the speed of-- as you
master it and it
becomes more complicated
because of things moving
faster or some kind
of additional complexity.
But good.
Well done.
PROFESSOR: So biggest risk?
Are you going to say it's art?
You mentioned the art.
STUDENT 6: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: What about the art?
Is it the UI art or the
representational art
that we talked about?
STUDENT 6: Yeah.
So it's mostly making sure
the representational art
aligns with-- what
we think of it
aligns with what our
intended players think of it.
And also just, like, we
have so much art to produce.
Like, getting it done.
PROFESSOR: The gameplay is
there, all the buttons work,
it's just getting
stuff onto that?
STUDENT 6: Also the conversation
UI, but our biggest risk,
I think, is the art.
STUDENT 7: It's
mostly functional.
There's a few bugs to iron out,
but the structure's all there.
PROFESSOR: OK.
Last questions?
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
All right.
Any generalized feedback you
want to give the whole class?
PABLO: Yeah.
You're now in a place where
you have on one hand more
to do than probably
you think you can,
but also more temptation to
do more things, new things,
explore new ways of
representing, et cetera.
It will be a balancing act.
In order to get a
passing grade you
have to deliver something
that works well enough.
I'll let them define that.
I invite you to
remain inquisitive
as to those simple-to-implement
new ideas that can help
something be really better.
So don't try to do
something really better that
require starting from scratch.
That'll be suicidal
at this stage.
But that balance is
a balance that you
will be experiencing throughout
the rest of your lives,
whether it's designing a
video game for the Red Cross
or designing, you know, rockets.
Good luck with it
all, and we'll have
more personalized conversations
after the half hour
presentation.
Thank you.
PROFESSOR: Thank you.
PABLO: And I'll be outside.
You let me know when.
PROFESSOR: We're done?
Do you guys need to take
a-- should we take a break?
Should we just keep going?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
10 minute [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
So we're going to take
a quick 10-minute break.
It's 1:50 right now.
So 2 o'clock.
If you want to talk about and
synthesize the feedback we just
gave you, do that right now.
On the presentations
you just gave.
You did really well.
You knew the problems that
you had, which is good,
because I was worried on
playtest that you might not
know some of the issues that
you were seeing in the playtest.
So that's good.
We're really glad to see that.
The big challenge I
see for your future
is planning for fixing those--
responding to those problems
that you know.
There's just a lot of
unforeseen stuff that
can happen between now
and the end of class,
and that is what my talk
is going to be about,
is how to plan for disaster.
And part of that is, just
don't have the disaster.
Cut it from the get go.
So let me just make
sure this is up.
Next.
All right.
You have deadlines.
This is the creative process.
Deadlines happen at
the end of the process.
Hopefully work happens
before the process.
In this class your deadline is
the last day of class, right?
Double check your Stellar,
you might be surprised.
In the real world
some of your deadlines
are going to be demo days.
E3.
Anybody heard the term E3 demo?
And soul-crushing-E3
demo, and studio
closed after failure of E3 demo?
Basically, show your game
off to a bunch of press
and hope it works.
Usually that means don't
allow any press to play it.
You just play it for them.
And by playing it for them,
that might be just showing them
the video while you
manipulate the controller.
You don't get to do
that in this class.
Other terms you might
hear from the industry.
Going gold.
It's not just for disco.
It is-- the Gold Master
there on the left side,
that's a game that went gold
and actually was canceled.
It got all the way
to Gold Master,
and then they said, no,
we're not going to ship it.
We're not going to produce it.
It's just not good enough.
That can happen.
Ship dates.
Back in the day games
came in these things
called boxes made out of
cardboard with printed
graphics that were in
interesting-- Eidos
would make them in
these trapezoidal things
so they wouldn't quite
fit on the shelf.
So you would see--
that's an Eidos product.
Thief-- were you on this
one, Thief, The Dark Project?
SARA VERILLI: Yep.
PROFESSOR: Yep.
Tomb Raider as well.
Again, you don't exactly
have a boxed ship date,
but you have a give us a
playable version of the game
ship date.
So how much time
do you have left?
December 10.
You have 17 days
left between now
and then to finish your game.
Well, let's assume you
don't work on Thanksgiving.
Anybody going home to
see family or anything?
A good portion of you.
Are you going to work while
you're with your family?
Maybe you're going to try.
Maybe you're in a turkey coma,
or veggie turkey coma for me.
But what about the
presentation week?
So December 8 and
10, you're actually
in class working on
your presentations.
Hopefully your game works by the
start of class on December 8.
Hopefully.
We're actually going to
recommend that you do not
change your game on
December 8 and December 10,
and you do a thing
we call "soak,"
which I'll talk about later.
It's totally up to you to do it.
I offer it every year.
It's almost never taken.
But I'm offering it.
So actually, was that 13 days
or was it really 30 hours?
You've got 12-- this is
a 12-hour-a-week course.
I took out the time that you're
actually spent here in lecture,
that I'm stealing from you.
Sorry.
I like talking sometimes.
So you really have
less than 1 work week
to get all this stuff done.
So think about that when you're
thinking about your projects.
Can you do all this in
one regular professional,
less than 40 hour work week?
So that's scary.
How do you meet your deadline?
Do you crunch or do you cut?
Who's heard the
word crunch before?
Just raise your hand
it you've heard it.
All right.
Raise your hand if you do crunch
right now, if you are actually
in the middle of crunch,
not even on this class
but in other classes.
Yeah.
As students, you already
know how to crunch.
You do this.
This is your daily life.
And it's expected in some
cases, it's some problems
with the system, guess what?
The same problems in
the game industry.
There is a way to do crunch--
to do a viable crunch.
And that's actually what
next week is probably
going to be for you,
is your crunch week.
So ways you can do
crunch and ways crunch
is viable in the actual,
real world industry.
You spend a limited
time period in crunch.
So if you hear
about death marches,
that's not a limited time.
That can be months,
years spent working
80-hour days on some studios,
unnamed, in Australia.
We're recommending
spending one sprint.
If you do a planned
sprint we say, in advance,
that we are going to
crunch on this week.
That means we're going to spend
that week picking up the slack
and getting through
a bunch of stuff
and we're going to work
a long period of time.
And it's going to be awesome.
Because guess what?
It's voluntary.
It is team-driven.
We decided, as a
team, to do this.
The management did not say, you
are going to crunch right now.
And in fact, a lot of
game industry would say,
that's not even crunch.
You're having too much fun.
That can't be crunch.
For them crunch is
compulsory, unpaid over-time.
Three words that I despise.
So if you are going to
crunch and it is voluntary
and you plan for
it in advance, you
would follow it by deep soak.
Deep soak, in this case, means
test, play, itemize bugs.
It means you are
playing your game,
you are understanding every
subtle nuance of the user
experience of your game.
You probably have a very good
understanding of the programmer
experience of your game, of
the artist, of the producer,
of the person on the team.
You know how your game ticks
from your point of view.
But you don't yet know it from
the players point of view,
even after focus testing,
even after seeing
other players play it.
You probably haven't
played your game
enough to really
understand what's going on.
What it actually
does from the get go.
So you play it a lot,
you itemize bugs,
you prioritize bugs,
you write bugs down,
but you don't actually fix them.
You just see what they
are, see how bad they are,
decide whether or not afterwards
you want to fix them or not.
All right.
So that's how you do crunch.
I give that to you.
You will probably do it.
That is OK.
Good luck.
But, advanced course.
If you want to cut features,
this is how you cut features.
So from now until
December 8, ask yourself,
can you ship your
game right now?
That's part of the
aspect of sprint, right?
At the end of a
sprint you should
be able to ship your game.
It's a viable product.
I can send it over the
wall, someone can play it,
and it is good and ready to go.
In order to do that--
and in this talk
I'm assuming that,
in order to do this,
you're going to need to
reduce the scope of your game
because you need
to ship it soon.
So what can you cut?
Some developers say these are
the only things you should cut.
Features that are not
fun and features that
do not advance the game's goals.
So play the game a lot.
Decide whether or not
those features are fun,
collect evidence for it, have
a theory about what is fun
or what is not fun,
identify those features
that go towards that
theory and remove them.
Just don't even continue
working on them.
In this case you're
thinking about the game
from the idea of your player
and your stakeholders.
These are basically features
that if you spent more time,
it would not be time well-spent.
But there's some other ones.
There are features that are
too big to be finished in time.
Really take a realistic look at
your product backlog right now
and decide if you can
finish it in time or not.
Could you cut those features?
Just give it a moment's thought.
Think about it.
Features that just don't work.
Why bother fixing something
if it's just going
to stay broken in two weeks?
Can you cut it?
Can you just remove it?
Does it change the game or not?
Can you even fix
these in time anyway?
You just have to
look at it and you
have to analyze it and decide.
So how would you actually
go ahead and do that?
Hopefully you can say
yes to these things.
Is your product backlog
currently prioritized
right now?
Did you estimate
your features well?
So did you estimate the
size and the time it
takes to create the features?
And did you create good blocks
of work in your sprints?
And my guess is, probably not.
And that's OK.
We talked to you about Scrum,
we talked to you about Agile.
The thing is, Scrum
is not a process.
Scrum is people doing a process.
You could be the best
person, the best programmer
in the world and
be put onto a team,
and still have all the problems
that you're having right
now because the team doesn't
know each other that well.
That's one of the things we
try to do on the first couple
projects, is get
you used to working
with the other
people in the class
so you can find people
that you've compatible work
styles with.
So that when you're
in project four
you have a chance at
forming a good, solid team
and having some team dynamics.
And remember when I
talked about team dynamics
earlier in the semester?
Would anybody say that they
are in the performing mode?
Like, do you feel like
you are performing well?
Do you have an engine going?
Do you see tasks get done?
Do they just fall off the list
because, oh, that was done.
That was verified.
That was awesome.
Has that happened yet?
Probably not.
That's OK.
Yeah.
A lot of head-shaking.
That's OK.
So we need something
else we can try out,
because that's
not going to work.
And even in the
ideal world, you're
still going to have to cut.
Like, developers cut
features every day.
Those are the tools
they have to use them,
but when those fail
we have other tools.
So based on what I read
from your project three,
some people think
cutting features
means dropping features.
That's slightly different.
It's not exactly the same.
The difference between a cut
feature and a dropped feature?
A cut feature has intention.
You've planned for it.
You're going to tie up loose
ends around the feature
after you've removed it
from the feature list.
You'll actually even delete
the feature from your product
backlog, and feel
really good about it,
and not have to ever worry about
it again because it's gone.
It's no longer going
to be in there.
Dropped features
are those things
at the bottom of
the backlog that
just don't get into
the game at the end
and could cause major
issues if they're
connected to other systems.
So how do you have
that intention?
You think through
the dependencies.
Scrum does not have a good tool
for identifying dependencies.
It's actually one of
its weakest points.
It assumes that, if you
do all the other stuff
your dependencies will just
fall into place because you've
created really
good backlog items
and you've organized them well.
So this is one of
those things where,
if you had a couple
more weeks maybe
you would want to
switch to waterfall
or go into a Gantt
chart or figure out
a way to graph every
little thing that's
going on in the game.
And I'm going to
say, don't do that.
But think about that
and get in that mindset.
So take a look at your code
and backlog for dependencies.
And here's one really easy
thought experiment to take.
look at your biggest
unfinished feature
and just think what would
happen if you just didn't do it.
So in one of the games
I saw-- this team here.
One of these teams.
You two teams over here.
What's your biggest
unfinished feature right now?
Either team.
Somebody just say it out loud.
Maybe Matt, while he's chewing.
Or somebody else.
AUDIENCE: Our time to gather
all the clues in our endgame.
PROFESSOR: Time to gather
all the clues in the endgame.
That's your biggest
unfinished one?
What would happen if
you just didn't do that?
AUDIENCE: There would be
no purpose to the game.
PROFESSOR: OK.
[LAUGHTER]
So is it still the same game?
Not really.
Would the other features
feel its absence?
Hells yes.
All right.
So trace your dependencies,
take a look at that thing,
go down the line and see, what
all the other systems that
are tied into it?
This is where graphing
could be helpful.
A little mind map, node map.
If I wasn't crunching and
actually made this presentation
this morning, I would
have had that graph.
But can you identify
the loose ends?
And then if you've cut those
loose ends off of that feature,
is your primary feature usable,
understandable, and polished?
You don't have to do this
for every single feature
on your feature list, but
identify one or two really
big ones and just do a
little thought experiment
and see what would
happen if they went away.
Because they're going
to go away at some
point in the next
week and a half.
So you've identified a feature
and you're going to say,
we're going to cut this feature.
We're not going to drop
it, we're going to cut it.
What exactly does that mean?
So think cut plus.
So cut the feature, replace
it with a different, smaller
feature.
Key word there is smaller.
Based on new knowledge
you know your game
better now than you
knew it when you first
made that product backlog.
That fits a similar purpose.
This is an OK solution.
It takes a little bit
of time and you actually
might be too late to
do that right now.
An example could be, you've got
a first person shooting game
and you have rocket
launchers, but you
don't have animated missiles.
Cut the rocket launcher.
You have-- what
else do you have?
You need another weapon.
You need another big weapon.
Maybe you have a ray gun.
Maybe you can already
animate things
on top of another character.
So you have a ray gun that
if you press the button,
anybody in front of the button
has a little animation that
vaporizes and dies.
You've got a very
similar feature going on.
It's a cool weapon.
It's damage heavy.
You don't need to
do that animated
bullet, that animated
missile, and you save yourself
some time.
And you haven't hurt the game.
The player doesn't even know
that that wasn't even there.
You didn't give the
player a rocket launcher
that didn't fire missiles,
and just made people randomly
blow up.
You've given them something
different and new and exciting.
Next one, cut and redesign.
So take the same feature
and then shrink it.
Redesign it for a smaller scope.
Again, based on new knowledge.
I'm playing the new
Pokemon right now.
Pokemon, that really
outrageous, complex, matrix
of strength and weaknesses.
When you break it down
it's rock, paper, scissors.
I'm trying to make a game and
I want to out-Pokemon Pokemon.
I'm going to have
modifiers for everything,
I'm going to have even longer
lists of different enemy types.
Maybe I just need
to go back to rock,
paper, scissors, do
a thought experiment,
create a short little prototype.
That's one thing
you can do right now
is you can create paper
prototypes on your own.
You've got big enough teams that
one person can say, let me do
a really quick paper
prototype of that feature
to see what it would look like.
Let me look at all the
previous features we have,
make sure it matches, and
come up with a little paper
version of it and
see, is that going
to fit the same thing or not?
And if it does, great.
You've saved yourself
a ton of time.
[? Today in ?] content, as we
saw in the presentations today.
Content is ginormous.
Churning through
that is really hard.
Lastly, cut and amplify.
Take an already developed
feature and make it better.
So did you promise 32
guns for your shooter?
Could 20 just be enough?
And then spend that time
you have with those 20 guns
to make them better
and more polished.
So I already went back to guns.
That's just where
my head was today.
If you think, if
you had one good,
really, awesome weapon-- double
sawed-off shotgun in Quake,
maybe.
That was pretty cool.
I used that one a lot.
And then a bunch of poorly
developed ones-- BFG.
I don't even understand why
they even put that in there.
Was that in Quake or
was it just in Doom?
AUDIENCE: Doom.
PROFESSOR: But
either way, though.
You rarely saw it.
It was cool for one second.
Maybe if that was a hugely
important, expensive thing,
maybe cut it and the player
doesn't even feel it.
So in all three of
these things when
we're cutting the feature
what we're thinking about
is, what does the player see?
Does the player
have-- what did I say?
Expected feedback.
If you drop a feature
might the player
still expect some
feedback that they're not
getting because that
feature's no longer there?
If you cut it the
player should never
know that it wasn't there.
Here's a game where
they dropped features.
This is one of our favorite
examples from 2003, Big Rigs.
Where's my mouse?
Anybody played it?
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-Hey, kids.
Strap yourself in for
some action-packed racing.
It's Big Rigs.
18 wheels of thunder,
and we got trucks.
Yeah, trucks.
Big Rigs.
Off-road traction.
More power for non-stop
driving action.
Big Rigs.
PROFESSOR: It's Big
Rigs off-road driving.
You can drive off the road.
-Who knows?
Big Rigs.
Never lose a race again.
You're always winner
with Big Rigs.
PROFESSOR: You always win,
every time you get through it.
There's no timer.
-Phasing molecular mechanics
to pass through solids--
PROFESSOR: Whoa!
- --so as not to interrupt--
PROFESSOR: Is this the future?
-Nothing stands in your
way when you're Big Rigs.
Rear-spinning tires
with warp-drive velocity
for inter-dimensional exploring.
Leave the game behind and exceed
the boundaries of existence!
PROFESSOR: This game shipped.
This game was put on a
disk, was put in a box,
was delivered to your local
game store and Walmart.
People bought it, I think.
-Big mother-fuckin' Rigs!
-Big Rigs.
[END PLAYBACK]
PROFESSOR: Yeah, that was
advertised as the trailer.
I quickly found out it
wasn't, but I kept it anyway.
Humor.
Oh, where's my mouse?
No!
[INAUDIBLE] speaker notes.
[INAUDIBLE] back.
Apologies.
There.
[INAUDIBLE] here, down there.
All right.
So that is the ultimate
expression of dropped features.
And-- oh, and I
forgot to copy this.
All right.
So another example
of cut features.
This is The Sims 4.
This is a quote from the
executive producer, Rachel
Franklin.
Basically what happened was,
when the game shipped-- well,
right before the
game shipped, players
identified that
through whatever they
did-- I think through
watching community forums,
listening to what the developers
were talking about the game--
they identified 89 features
missing from The Sims 4.
89 features that were not
in Sims 4 when it shipped.
How did they know
about those features?
Well, they were in Sims
1, 2, and 3 but they
didn't put them in 4, so
they should be in 4, right?
Basically, she says "I want
to put everything we've ever
created in the last 14
years into a base game,
but we simply can't.
What we have done instead is
to create an incredibly rich,
robust experience.
If we didn't build
the core foundation
but I gave you pools, that
wouldn't be the right thing
to do."
They didn't quite meet
the player experience.
There could've been some
things that-- maybe there
were some problems
going on the production,
but they decided that they
still needed a core game that
could work because they
could always add some
of those features in later.
There are some people
on the forums who say,
no, that's actually not going
to be working in the game engine
because I'm the nerd on the
internet knows everything
and I know you can't
do that, developer
who actually made the game.
So that is a problem that they
knew they were going to have.
They know that they have
it when they ship the game.
They have to come up
with a community response
to figure that out.
And actually, that's something
we'll talk about next week when
it comes to
community management,
is when you're creating this
game and people find out
about this game, how do
you then talk them down?
But actually, in
the most part you'll
be talking about
bringing them up.
All right.
So we're going to
cut some features.
We're not going to drop them.
So who decides which
features are going to cut?
Who decides what
and when, and then
who's going to implement it?
How are we going to do this?
So the people who decide
which features get cut usually
are the stakeholders.
In the professional
world that's going
to be that executive producer.
For you that could
be your client.
That could be your
product owner,
if you have a product
owner on your team,
if you have someone you consider
a vision owner on your team,
it could be that person.
It could default down to
producer or Scrum Master,
if that's the
person we're saying
that we're following
their lead, they're
going to make that decision.
It could be your game designer.
But it's going to be
somebody on your teams.
One, maybe two
people on your teams
who are coming up at least
with the what and the when.
Not everybody on the team
knows the schedule as well as
maybe the producer does.
But the who implements and
how it's implemented-- that's
the entire team's job.
This is why we have those
long, boring Scrum meetings
at the beginning and
the end of each sprint.
It's because that's
the time period when
we have all the team together to
make these kinds of decisions.
It's definitely not the
producer and Scrum Masters' role
to decide how you're
going to cut that feature.
They're there to
facilitate it and make sure
that everybody who's attached to
that feature can talk about it,
can explain why, can
give some argument,
can give some defense.
Rather than giving the
entire team the need
to decide everything,
one or two people
decide the initial part
and then the whole team
focuses on just how we're
going to cut those things.
And that's because
how you implement
it requires knowledge of
both code and content.
It's more than a feature list.
A feature list can't
do this for you.
It can do the top, it can show
you the what, but never the
how.
All right.
Last little section.
So you were working on a feature
and your feature was cut.
You spent a lot of
time on that feature.
Your roll was to
implement networking.
And this is actually an
example from two years ago.
But was cut.
In that case, it wasn't cut
because of these things.
I don't want to cut it.
I want to see this finished.
I put some commitment
into this thing, dammit.
I want to see this
all the way through.
I feel guilty about cutting it.
I really let my team down.
I was just working on
networking the entire semester,
and it's not going to
make it into the game.
What have I been doing?
I feel sad about cutting it.
It's not fair.
How dare you cut my feature?
You're going to see a lot of
that, if you haven't already.
But that's OK.
One thing to keep
in mind when you're
cutting a feature--
and this is one thing
that we told that person--
was, your work needed
to happen because otherwise you
wouldn't know that we needed
to know about your work.
You described this
better, by the way.
SARA VERILLI: I'm trying to
remember exactly what I said,
but it's something
to the effect of,
sometimes the work that
doesn't make it into the game
had to happen anyway
because you had
to do the work to
explore networking
to find out if it
wouldn't work or not.
Just like you had to
do the work to explore
several other features
that did go into the game.
But you didn't know
that the-- I don't
know-- you didn't know
which of those features
were going to work out well.
But you were hoping
that some of them would.
Some of them did,
some of them didn't.
The fact that one
particular feature-- the one
that you worked on-- is
not a reflection on you.
Not at all.
It's a reflection on the
game, and the project
needs to go forward.
PROFESSOR: Absolutely.
So yeah.
Work that gets cut
is never wasted work.
And that's actually
a problem I have
when game developers
do their postmortems
and post in the Gamasutra is
they always talk about it as
if it was wasted work.
But really, again, they wouldn't
have had that information
had they tried it.
Work well-cut is
exploratory work.
It means that you cut it early
enough that it was exploratory.
You got your feelers around it.
You figured out
that was probably
a direction you didn't want to
go into, and you pulled back.
And actually you did
that in the beginning
with your paper prototypes.
I don't think your
games now actually are
one-to-one relationships
to those paper prototypes
you created at the
beginning of this project.
And you threw those
away, and it was OK.
So why is this important?
Because the team is more
important than the product,
which is, unfortunately,
more important than you.
But that's OK, because
the team equals you
plus others in the
same situation.
You are actually
part of the team.
So just keep that in mind.
This is where I go to my
Goodfellas-- was it Goodfellas?
There's no I in
team, baseball bat?
You are on a team.
Everyone's contributing to it.
Everyone's doing
good work for it.
All right. so that's my
spiel on cutting features.
Here is my-- what I'd
like to do on Wednesday.
So Wednesday is going
to be a short class.
We're just meeting
from 1:00 to 2:00.
You'll have the remainder of
the time to work in your group,
in your teams you as you like,
but if you want to take off,
you can take off.
What we are going
to do-- and it's
going to be me, Phillip, and
Drew, because unfortunately
Sara won't be here--
is we're going
to meet with each of your teams
individually for about five,
seven minutes tops.
What we'd like to do is look
at an updated vision statement.
So between now and then take
a look at the vision statement
you turned into
Stellar, compare it
to the game you have
right now, and modify it.
The vision statement is your
publisher contract with us.
That vision statement that
you actually finally turn
in on December 10
with your game,
is the thing that we are
judging your game by.
If your game has
all the features
that are described in that
vision statement, then aces.
If you created a
vision statement that
doesn't have the
features are in the game,
or if you don't describe the
features well in the vision
statement then we're
going to use that
as an understanding of
what could have gone wrong
with that game.
This should be a really
quick thing you can do.
You can probably do this in five
minutes today with your team.
You have everybody
here right now.
You just had your presentations
about your products.
So if you can take five minutes
today, reassess your vision
statement, take a look at your
product backlog, change it.
We're going to talk about that.
You can re-turn
that in to Stellar
or you can bring in a
paper version on Wednesday,
so long as we can
see it when we're
sitting with you on Wednesday.
That's all we ask.
And again, like I
said earlier, plan
as if nothing is being done
over Thanksgiving, just in case.
If work happens over
Thanksgiving, cool.
You did good.
That's bonus work.
So just keep that in mind.
Any questions?
All right.
Pablo is back in the room.
And you're working on your
teams for the rest of the day.
Thank you.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]